[Music]
joining me today is a lawyer a gun
rights activists and the host of no are
on NRA TV colleano are welcome to the
Rubin report how's it going man how's it
going my friend it's going good it's
good to be in LA I am I'm glad to have
you know we've been trying to do this
for about a year
yeah yeah yeah I just like to think so
yeah it might just be a facade I put on
to avoid people but now and actually but
in reality now it's it's been it's been
a pretty busy year yeah like extremely
so and it doesn't ever seem to slow up
and just what I think it does something
else jumps off well if you think coming
on this show is gonna help slow it down
you are sorely mistaken
yeah well I'm a bit of a masochist in
that regard we'll see by the time this
hour is done work on earth hell we can
write I'm pretty sure there will be some
yeah well don't worry because there will
be equal amounts on me just for a
sitting here with you that's the
interesting thing
you know I it's I don't want to say I've
been blind to it but just being just
seeing some of the reaction and
responses that I got especially for
instance when I was on Maher when I did
Bill Maher you know I saw some of the
comments from I say the other side just
for ease of communication yeah but for
people who largely don't agree with me
in his audience they were like I would
drop the NRA guy on there even a I was a
tweet I responded to yesterday and even
though I was on my no tweeting do that I
like to put myself on because so toxic
in there sometimes how often do you do
that
happy 30 minutes I'm trying to do
weekends and disappearing at all of
August see it man
Twitter's toxic man when you're in the
lane that you and I are in yeah it's
toxic man and it can really even though
you don't think you're taking that in
even just kind of scrolling through
you're taking it in yeah you know and in
it it's like I constantly I developer
this pattern of just yeah don't respond
to that cuz they're baiting you yeah I
mean things of that nature but um I was
I saw a tweet and she's like yeah I
loved Omar oh I love this episode but
you have that NRA guy on it I'm like
Jesus are we not allowed to have
discourse anymore
if especially if it disagrees with with
something that you believe in oh and you
know like this is a very
we're going down if that's good if
that's gonna be the case because you
forget you know we live in this country
together yeah and we're not all the same
there's about 350 million other yeah
might not all think the same thing
exactly pretty crazy it's it's kind of
sad some it will least for me it's a
little disheartening yeah because I grew
up under the guise and understanding the
importance of discourse and being able
to talk things out even if you do
disagree with someone but didn't even
still having the ability to set aside
whatever views I may have on a
particular issue and then be able to
speak of you cordially or have respect
for you even though we don't agree
that's the way I was brought up in so to
see the country kind of falling into
this extremely of erotic divisiveness it
it's a hardening yeah you know I don't
wanna get all emo on you you don't have
to guess cried till the end but that's
exactly why I wanted to have you on
because you you are okay going into
enemy territory I'm not on this enemy
turns yeah but you did you did Mars show
where you knew a certain percentage of
the audience was just gonna hate you
yeah and we talked about it briefly
right before we started but you found
Maher to be basically pretty pretty
respected even kill yeah okay even
though I'm policy he probably disagrees
with you with 8080 pretty much yeah and
you know and it was something that I
ended up respecting about him and in
that regard cos like I said I I kind of
I went in prepared for I didn't go in to
do war but I went and prepared for it
you know it was like prepared for the
worst hope for the best and I tell you I
got the best in a sense of it was a it
was a discourse where he challenged me
but it wasn't this kind of tumultuous
kind of flooding of the heads where it
just turned into something that was just
ugly yeah well he wasn't trying to get
yet yeah trying to understand you
because that that you know I'm trying to
do that here I there's a couple other
places where people are trying to do
that but yeah that's the thing that's
been lost and that's an interesting
thing you point out there it's I think
sometimes people take offense to that
idea it's like I don't your intruder
intriguing I think intrigue kind of
offends people sometimes because it's
like we all grow up with a typical
understanding what we expect certain
people to be like and then when certain
things don't fit it's like that's
interesting how did you get there right
and I think when it's innocent like that
I don't think there's an issue there
when you use it to try to kind of muscle
people into believing a certain thing
based on what they are then that's when
we start having problems you know what I
mean it's like you see me it's like how
do you as a black guy like it happened
to me when I first started doing what I
did with the NRA Russell Simmons and
I'll never forget this I was like I was
like in Virginia Beach I think and
Russell said I I did my first sets of
videos and rolled out with the NRA and I
get this tweet from Russell Simmons and
he's like how can you as a young black
man push Daddy you get you know the
typical rhetoric in that regard even
though he often is all about trying to
get people to exactly which is really
yeah and so I responded I said you know
like I didn't know advocating for self
defense and self-reliance was a bad
thing I didn't know that only non black
people are allowed to do that right and
so that was kind of like my first foray
into that world of wait a minute people
have an expectation of me based on my
race that I'm not gonna say I was
oblivious to but it just when it was
coming from people that look like me as
well with the same level of intensity
that's when I go WOW okay alright so
here that's what this is yeah okay so I
won I want to back up to a little bit of
childhood and growing up because you're
evolutions kind of dream but let's just
say with this for one second because I
think there's something really
interesting about that thing right there
that often if you listen to the media
they'll tell you that police are hunting
down black men and all of this and then
at the same time you're saying well we
should be able to arm ourselves and
protect ourselves from the white
supremacist but meaning that lawfully
and legally we should be able to take
care of ourselves if you believe that
the system is so corrupt and the police
are so corrupt and there's racists
running around everywhere you're trying
to bring the power back to yourself
that's to me that's very empowering yet
somehow this seemingly is lost when this
conversation hits the mainstream it's
amazing I don't understand it it's like
in one breath you're talking about let's
let's take the colonel ministration for
instance
paint it as this the most vicious and
vile thing on a planet and then it's
like well then let's give the same guns
that you have for your own self reliance
I would you would use to protect
yourself against this monster that you
said existed and let's give it to them
and then place your entire reliance with
respect to your safety on the same
people you you're telling me I should be
scared of it doesn't you're horrible
give them your weapons what it's it's
mind-blowing right and so what it does
though it exposes this notion that the
there's a absence of ability to I don't
say mobility or people just choosing not
to critically think mm-hmm you know and
we're at a point now where we have
access and that's like it amazes me some
of the questions that I get and it's
like you literally have a device that
gives you access to all of the
information in the world in the case of
my overabundant ass I have two of them
right and it's like it takes you to
follow I assume you have like eight guns
on you at all right yeah you know and
it's it's amazing how when we have such
access to so much information we've
become so lazy at reaching for it this
was almost like back in the day when we
didn't have this access we we more
adamant about search searching and
seeking it out and critically thinking
about things it's almost we become too
fast for our own good right so the
obsession now is instant information
into the information regardless of
whether or not the information is of any
use or good or the or if it's even
correct yeah you know and so it's it
hate it because you know I logged I've
done all of those things and I actually
people get mad at me when I don't jump
on a certain issue quick enough and when
I say cook enough within 30 seconds I'll
see that sometimes it goes down in the
news and a literally two minutes go by
or I'm at dinner and I wasn't looking my
phone and then I'll get a slew of tweets
people I see you didn't comment on he
must be in on it
good god paid off god forbid it involves
a black person and there's a gun within
10 miles I have to jump on it yeah you
know and in their some cases I
understand there are some people who do
who are just now getting into this who
are just now getting in the fire
and they are black right and you know
maybe they look to me for understanding
and direction because I've been doing it
for so long so that I understand but but
other people it's just this constant
desire to be like ah ha I got you I knew
you were [ __ ] the kind of deal right and
it's like like give me 30 seconds to
even read the article you just sent me
ten seconds ago yeah right and then from
there and then not to mention you know
there's a thing called work that I do
so yeah I'm still doing that as well so
I'm you know I'm juggling a lot of
things I don't have to tell you you
probably 310 more articles to even
ascertain anything close to the truth
bingo and that's the one thing that I I
think a lot of people don't do and I
almost tweeted that the other day I go
you know it's very dangerous to read
headlines especially in the day and age
of clickbait titles to just read
headlines and then make an opinion based
off of that or think you know understand
what happened in a particular story
because there are so many articles that
I've read about me yeah and what I've
said where the headline said one thing
and to cover their asses within the
article they'll clarify exactly what
that what it is that I said but they're
banking on the idea that people are just
gonna read the headlines and then run
with that yeah and so it ends up making
a fool of you fool of people what's your
personal policy on that about how to
respond to that do you go all in on the
fight do you ignore it because I this
has happened to me not just in the last
week and daily be said I was an all
right cheerleader you're black I think
so how am i doing for the fur and all
right you you suck well no I mean but
this is the level of pity but but then
it's about how much time do you want to
invest in in defending yourself and by
doing that defense do you just add
intensity to the people going hi see we
can get him to defend himself and then
before you know your whole life is
dedicated to defending yourself from
fake attacks rather than doing the work
that you care about two things one
you're they do the teachers are
dangerous
you're dangerous not because you agree
with me in certain certain issues you're
dangerous in the fact that you're just
simply willing to talk to me
so for it's the same thing happened when
I did I did the interview with killer
Mike mmm-hmm
right they jumped all over him not
because of what he said
but just because he sat down I had the
conversation with me yeah half the time
they don't even listen oh that's that's
interesting you point it out because I'm
like how can anyone watch this interview
and not walk away with saying you know
that was a great conversation about two
people who don't agree on everything but
there's some things we agree on he's
like because they didn't watch it that
sounds like what do you mean it's like I
had just this weird blonde moment right
yeah I'm like what do you mean he's like
he didn't watch it he's like they don't
actually watch the video they just read
the title and then assume they know what
happened in the video and then make
their opinion from there yeah I'm like
Danny right I hate going down the weeds
with too much of this because it feels
like we're just responding to all of the
craziness but even in the evenin like
the YouTube ecosystem yeah when we put
videos up sometimes within 10 seconds
there's a hundred comments that was an
hour I want that time machine because I
would be a lot more productive but it's
always the haters that do it that's why
I want to bring it up cuz it because
then that hate is the thing that's
always leading us and then I think that
brings it back to where you started a
moment ago which is that we're in this
polarized thing and because the haters
are sort of paving the road and everyone
else is just going down the road I think
a few of us are actually trying to find
a better Road that more of us can get I
the interesting thing about the
discourse the way it is now right and so
our politics have become our
entertainment that's the one that's the
dangerous aspect right so if it's not
vitriolic if it's not snarky if it's not
any of those things it people don't pay
attention to it and I'm the biggest
advocate of light all right look if you
if you don't agree with me on something
you're not to be an ass about it yeah
right now can I be snarky yeah no I can
absolutely be snarky but what I what I
tried to do to respond to your initial
question you asked him how do I like how
do I go all-in do I respond so like for
instance on Twitter what I've kind of
held myself back to doing now is if I
can tell that the person is later he's
seeking out an answer or response that's
I'm gonna give them that same energy in
terms of okay no let's let's have that
conversation right because there was a
point in time where everything I
responded to when I would spawn to it
through the lens of just being this
snarky has you know what I mean
and yeah sure was i entertaining myself
absolutely yeah but didn't I had to ask
myself was I really moving in
conversation in the dialogue along even
though it is Twitter right it's 20 it's
a dumpster fire right but what I started
has some importance it does just the
truth that's why it keeps coming up in
so many of these conversations we got
high-level people with great minds that
are open and engaging that are still
involved in the stupidity of that so
it's like when I bring it up with the
guests noise like I don't want to touch
that again and then on the other hand we
all know it's real it just it just is
whether we want it to be or not
everybody said whether we like not just
the meaning of expression right now and
so we have to you know it's like you
either adapt to die yeah but you know
it's it's I try I try to be what it is I
I tried to be the opposite of what I
could plane about at least I try in
terms of like sometimes I'll see snarky
messages and then I'll respond by trying
to be reasonable I'll say okay I get it
you don't like me but answer this
question for me and I try to move the
dialogue along you know what is up
happening to gets deleted yeah almost
every single time
yeah the second you shed a little light
on it Congrats scatter yeah yep what is
the before we dive too much into your
past what is the thing that they're
criticizing you most for like you come
across to me as a pretty rational mm-hm
decent open guy you're trying to empower
yourself okay so what is it that they're
always going after you is is it that
thing that a black man shouldn't be for
guns I mean is it that's simply stupid
so I'm like so I don't not gonna be so
naive as to assume it's simply just
because I'm blacking them in the gun
yeah they're alright thing holds up
that's the part of it that's a big part
of it
it's just aligning myself an
organization that they seemingly that
they see as being a racist organization
that hates black people okay we're gonna
talk plenty about the internet right so
there's that element of it but then
there's there is also this idea that
being young black men that I'm supposed
to run from guns because of the
projected image that we've all had
forced down our throats with respect to
black men in firearms in this country
for decades
you know black man with a gun he's a
thug he's drug dealers and getting
banger
so now when I young attorney educated
open-minded and deal with respect to
different issues and then I'm pushing
the narrative of the Second Amendment it
sets off an explosive level of cognitive
dissonance and people who have what I
love this quote and I believe was Bush
who said it
this soft bigotry of low expectation
right and it they hate it I hate it the
same way they they hate you now because
you can't control someone who's willing
to think independently outside of what
is stereotypically expected of you right
and that's where the labels come in and
so it's like you go do progressive
you're liberal you know so forth wrong
but you still have that ability to step
outside of that and say you know what
let me mean okay I can see that
perspective that's dangerous for people
who want to control people so when I
want to control the way you think the
way you see yourself I cannot allow you
to develop an ability to think
independently on separate issues because
then I can't control you so if I if I
say you know what I can do everything
for you depend on me the last thing I
want you to do and understand is you
know what wait a minute you mean tell me
I can protect myself you mean to tell me
I don't have to depend on calling a cop
in order to come save me if someone does
try to break into my house because then
I can't control you
I can't own your vote because what the
gun has done from me and a lot of people
it serves as a catalyst for the
awakening of a lot of people to
understand you know what I can do more
for myself than I realize you know and
once that once that spark is set off
then a lot of things you start to
realize you know I don't you know what
maybe you know now that I'm holding
myself to a different level of
accountability maybe I might try to do
this on my own you know doesn't it just
feel good I mean putting aside I know a
lot of people are into facts over
feeling these days right Shapiro but
doesn't that statement right there that
that you can do more for yourself it
just feels good like making some power
back to yourself and going the
government or you whoever you are that
are not in charge of my life my
responsibility my livelihood my family
the rest of it it's the most
rating feeling in the world and I'm with
you I'm all about backs over feelings
and I mean it from the standpoint I
don't allow my feelings to dictate the
facts you know I do think feelings are
necessary right because we because
within the absence of them we just
become cold calculated creatures right
and we are still human we are getting
you know what I mean so it's like now at
least all right so you know when I talk
about the issue of firearms I do
Dibley try to inquire I was having a
discussion with a lady not too long ago
about just general firearm issues with
respect to her son all right who's the
young black man and I asked her you know
like the are you fearful of the idea of
him carrying a gun and so forth and so
on and I have to bring myself back when
I'm having a discussion with someone
like that because I don't have kids
right so yeah am i Godfather that yeah
so no however but it's not the same that
for a woman who has a son so I have to
be cognizant of that and understand what
goes into that when she's thinking about
whether or not she she's okay with him
owning a firearm and and then on top of
that having this idea that her son is
more likely to get killed by a cop
because he has a gun on him versus when
he doesn't you know and that's where the
feeling component comes in where it's
necessary I think you if you can't
sympathize with that then it makes you
dismissive and so then that person can't
relate to you then we can't have that
conversation yeah you know what I mean
and that comes from personal experience
absolutely because when I was reading
your bio there I mean there's really
interesting stuff about how you evolved
sort of politically and personally but
when you started getting into guns you
kind of had to hide it yeah from your
mom even so everyone little bit about
about growing up and then sort of your
kind of politics and then how do we have
we got so into gun gotcha so I I grew up
largely a closeted anti-gun ER I didn't
realize all sounds like gonna to the
world there was one present right I
wasn't kind of rapidly running running
out scream yeah I hate guns or anything
like that but when a woman was president
I remember there's one moment when I was
in college had a roommate when her
friends brought a gun over I was like
you need to get to hell on my part
get out of my apartment and um well had
a good friend of mine who randomly just
asked me hey do you want to go to range
never even thought about it and I've
even crossed my mind which is how I know
a lot of times I can decipher based on
certain comments whether or not
somebody's actually commenting from a
place of ignorance or a place of
understanding because I was that guy
never even thought about going to range
never thought about shooting a gun but
to tell you all the opinions in the
world why that's right and so when I
hear that rhetoric now I can usually
point it out and like you've never shot
before you've never even held a gun
before and so from that perspective we
went to the gun range and a shot for the
first time and I was hooked now I was
hooked not from a political standpoint
now what not even from an empowering oh
my god I can protect myself now
standpoint it was just pure fascination
with the mechanics the physics all of it
I'm very kind of like curious mind so
for me it was like kind of like this
like the idea that I'm launching a
projectile faster than the speed of
sound a little target like a hundred
yards away like that was awesome so
first shot you were her first shot
terrified the second side I was like
lovely that's a little bit second shot
all right right so from that perspective
that I just I follow that rabbit all the
way down the hole but it was like I said
it was more from a scientific mechanical
understanding of it then as time went on
then I started looking at it from more
intellectual second-amendment political
activist standpoint and then I started
my then the lawyer mind kicked it mm-hmm
and then and I started looking I'm like
I'm hearing something we could be during
the time period then that particular
time period we had a couple of pretty
big mass shootings that happened and so
I started paying it and so I'm now
paying attention more to the skylight
when you're thinking about buying a car
and you never see it on the road and
once you start thinking about buying you
can see it everywhere that's pretty much
what happened now so I'm like I'm
hearing the conversation about guns
everywhere now and I'm like no this is
making any sense logically like what
people are proposing it doesn't it was
so pure it wasn't like an agenda drums
like this doesn't make sense to me it's
like a window like a stick on a window
is not gonna stop somebody from bringing
a gun in just saying that is illegal
you mean the sign that says No
I mean the bad guys not gonna read the
sign to be like exactly go to the other
place right so that's kind of when I
started jumping into the more activist
advocate side of things with respect to
the Second Amendment yeah and when you
first got guns yeah you were literally
hiding them where I was from your mom
yeah cuz cuz cuz she was very much I
mean she was a single parent mom raising
black son she wanted to port every
stereotype on the planet right
my mom overcompensated with me
tremendously because she under she
understood in her mind the limitations
that come with being a woman raising a
man by herself
so she overcompensated so where it's
like usually typically have like mama's
boys who are just calling mom does
everything for this [ __ ] wash your own
clothes come here go do everything she
made me and I at the time I just thought
she was just being a mean mom all right
not realizing you know it was her
overcompensating from the stand point
it's like I got to make this - I got to
raise a man yeah right and so but so she
was trying to buck so I knew once I
started getting into guns no no cuz the
perception was black man with gun gang
banger right and you know she had some
insecurities in that she's like you know
like they're gonna come a point where
I'm not gonna be able to control this
kid I don't know who's gonna be doing
and so I didn't want to terrify her and
make her think that I was living some
nefarious lifestyle that she and it was
almost a way to protect her more than
was to hide it from my sake because I
didn't want her to feel like she
actually failed as a mother
and so I knew if she saw the ak-47 that
I had hidden under my bed in her mind
she knows nothing about guns all she
knows is what she sees in the media in
New York who touched upon before that
imagery is not positive so she comes
home sees ak-47 in bed she's oh my god
my son is a gay baby first he stayed
under the bed now you said in the bed is
there anything you want to tell me her
we talked about that lady
the irony behind it is I did this kind
of embarrassing cuz you know about
basketball fans I used to sleep with my
basketball oh yeah man yeah I ball was
life that was everything now you still
got any skills some some yeah I got some
I'm actually working on trying to for
the next NRA annual meetings put
together like a - a charity basketball
of it if you're down but I've never
slept with my guns down Freud all right
okay so so from that point when you
started getting okay with this now
you're exploring it as you said
intellectually yeah how long before you
were really an advocate for this stuff
because you always sort of wanted to
fight for something yeah I mean with you
here he was deaf net that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to be an advocate
I wanted to be in the courtroom
defending people that's that was my goal
like even to the detriment of my grades
like I focused more on like my mock
trial stuff when I was in law school
than I did my actual work like - like
school was right and I liked being the
voice for people I like being able to
speak to people who can articulate
certain things the way that maybe I can
and I never saw this coming the way that
they did but I'm doing exactly what I
always wanted to do and and for me with
the gun thing I remember being in like
I'd be in like class in law school and
the way they like the seats are
staggered they're like stadium seats
right so if I'm on my computer and
you're behind me you can see what I'm
doing on my computer and I gotta be in
class and like I'm researching guns and
stuff like that right yeah dude like
people and the thing is a lot of things
that were being said about me I didn't
even know about - later on people were
concerned yeah I really like goes like
no yeah he's like these crazies not you
know um I get it if you don't if you're
not into that kind of thing and you
don't follow it the idea of how being
passionate about something you perceive
to be a a tool that used for killing
people and only killing people it's
gonna seem to outdo you
but because I came to it so naturally so
organically without any of that
they just made sense in my mind I was so
unapologetic about it
so I got over being apologetic about it
that I didn't push it in people's faces
but you know there was there was even a
topic that's how my Instagram got
started was me separating so the people
who followed me up into that point you
know I had a girlfriend at the time was
like you know a lot of questions for
people you know think you can time to
tone down the gun stuff a little bit and
it was it was kind of an innocent you
know thing but I never led you said you
know forget it I'm just gonna set up a
whole nother page and now I'm just gonna
do all the gun stuff I want to do on
that page yeah
and now that's taken over I don't even
use the other one and I don't even know
if I remember the password but it's so
from there that's where things really
started taking off and then with the in
and then when I started cuz I started
doing gun reviews and so then from there
when I got into the political component
of it then I started talking doing my
commentary and the Nats when things
started really taking off
[Music]